non
d'empathie meurtrière sur le nord-ouest
au moins six morts en france 23 morts en
angleterre
l'assassinât du docteur peschard le
commanditaire présumé est un conseiller
municipal de marseille le dr gallot
enquête 19 20 à l'heure des
bouleversements alec radio free europe
n'a pas l'intention de fermer
ava gardner est morte l'actrice
américaine s'est éteint à 67 ans
aujourd'hui à londres
bonsoir et oui la star est morte
ava gardner a disparu nous l'avons
appris à 19 heures nous reviendrons bien
sûr sur la vie tumultueuse de havas
kasner avec henry chapier qui va nous
rejoindre tout à l'heure au cours de ce
journal mais tout d'abord la situation à
marseille où nous allons retrouver en
direct
robert vigouroux le maire de la ville
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
nous l'avons fait pour que vous
réagissiez à la triste actualité qui
secoue votre ville et votre équipe
municipale le commanditaire de
l'assassinât du docteur peschard tués le
16 janvier serait en effet un autre
médecin le docteur galop particularité
la victime et le coupable présumé était
tous les deux membres du conseil
municipal de votre conseil robert
vigouroux
oui c'est à la ville de marseille que je
pense c'est un crime de droit commun en
dehors de la politique en dehors de la
municipalité mais je suis bien conscient
de ce qui se passe de ce qui peut
rejaillir sur l'affairé et je pense
surtout à payer aux marseillais alors
vers les goûts je vous propose avant de
reprendre notre entretien de faire un
rappel des faits pour nos
téléspectateurs avec nathalie darrigrand
une balance un tueur est un
commanditaire la sphère pêcheurs a
décidément la couleur d'un thriller mais
aussi des eaux troubles la balance
marcel oms trafiquants de drogue connue
il prend peur en se reconnaissant sur
les portraits robots et dénonce le tueur
instruments robert mais molly le
commanditaire un politique
armand gallo médecin et conseiller
municipal de marseille affaire facile
pour les policiers presque trop facile
armand gallo aurait affirmé que jean
jacques béchard lui devait de l'argent
400 mille francs
un mobile bien mince pour un tel contrat
contrat dont l'exécution suscite aussi
des questions marcel non encore lui est
entré dans le restaurant peu avant le
meurtre de pêche à son attitude est
alors si troublante car marc des témoins
d'où les portraits-robots difficile ce
soir de lancer des affirmations donc des
accusations tout dépend en fait de
l'attitude d'armes en gallo qui devrait
demain être déféré au parquet de
marseille
robert vigouroux vous avez entendu notre
consoeur un mobile bien bien mince
dit-elle vous avez vous même parlé de
crimes de droit commun à votre avis la
raison de ce crime
je ne connais pas la raison la police a
agi très rapidement efficacement
maintenant c'est à la justice
effectivement je conçois mal un tel
mobile je me demande en comme tout un
chacun s'il n'y a pas autre chose mais
attentons avant de poursuivre de cerner
la personnalité du docteur armand galop
gabriel brisset de notre station de
marseille fait son portrait il enlève
ses lunettes
armand galop un médecin de 42 ans aux
dernières municipales
armand gallo est élu sur les listes
majorité marseille il devient conseiller
d'arrondissement du 7e secteur
ce secteur même où le maire n'était
autre que le docteur peschard pour
armand galop ce mandat au sein d'une
équipe municipale n'est pas une première
il avait déjà siégé l'hôtel de ville
entre 83 89 sous la bannière du rpr il
était venu à la politique dans le
sillage de hyacinthe sont ni c'est ici à
la clinique des roches clair dans les
quartiers nord de marseille
car manga l'eau exerce en partie sa
profession de médecin généraliste une
clinique dont on avait beaucoup parlé il
ya quelques mois à l'occasion de la
sphère chouraqui armand gallo n'exerce
pas fait dans cette clinique
il exerce aussi dans un cabinet qu'il
partage avec son frère dans le quartier
du canet d'où il est originaire reste le
mobile ce matin on reste perplexe une
dette de 400 mille francs semblait ma
vie bien minces faut-il alors fouillis
plus en avant dans ce monde décidément
bien obscurci des cliniques privées un
harcèlement et l'on revient sur la
raison tout le monde en doute je crois
qu'il faut le reconnaître franchement
monsieur le maire oui on parle de
cliniques le l'histoire de deux
cliniques
cela n'est pas de la gestion du maire de
marseille
je ne suis informé que comme les autres
par les médias parlent et les journaux
les radios et les télés je dois dire que
nous avons un bon corps médical à
marseille de bon chirurgien de bons
médecins de lyon spécialiste al dans les
hôpitaux également dans des cliniques
privées
ce cette affaire des cliniques d'un
certain de cliniques je n'en sais pas
est ce que vous connaissez bien monsieur
gallo non je veux dire personnellement
il il est de votre équipe mais ce que
vous le connaissez bien personnellement
ce qu'est capable de faire ça monsieur
gallo faisait partie était conseiller
d'arrondissement effectivement il avait
été européenne il avait il avait changé
d'avis je ne le connais pas
personnellement il s'était engagé
politiquement pour une certaine gestion
de la de la ville de marseille
je n'en sais pas plus je retrouve un
article du point sur vous monsieur
robert d'égout qui date de 1986 robert
vigouroux n'est pas un homme de combines
ce qui fait figure de rareté à marseille
il apparaît comme un recours moral
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas atteint par
tout ce qui se passe dans votre ville et
dans votre équipe municipale
c'est là dans l'équipe n'est pas
atteinte c'est marseille
les faits sont les faits on doit les
reconnaître mais vous savez il ya
beaucoup de d'actions positives aussi à
marseille
nous n'avons pas le ruban bleu de la
criminalité à marseille je crois que des
statistiques vont bientôt paraître qui
le prouveront ce n'est pas à moi d'en
parler beaucoup de il ya des
travailleurs a lancé il ya toute une
population qui qui est là pour pour que
cette ville prospère mais il ya ceux
aussi qui n'ont pas de travail
c'est à eux que je pense en particulier
c'est pour eux que nous travaillons
c'est pour cette ville alors je suis un
petit peu choqué bien sûr par ce qui
s'est passé mais aussi par un certain
nombre de réactions purement
politiciennes qui chercha à se servir
d'un événement dramatique le jour des
fins qui ne sont pas d'un point de vue
éthique
les faits sont pas corrects ce monsieur
les goûts vous n'avez sans doute pas vu
un autre dessin de bape qui est par les
antennes sans doute un peu sévère est ce
qu'il n'ya pas une malédiction sur la
ville non ya pas de malédiction ça fait
26 siècles convient y a pas de
malédiction sur une ville qui au travers
d'événements difficiles a vécu pendant
vingt-six y est
merci monsieur vigouroux pour ces
précisions sur ce qui se passe dans
votre ville les spécialistes de la météo
ne se sont pas trompés
j'allais dire malheureusement la tempête
annoncée hier s'est bel et bien produit
aujourd'hui sur les côtes de la manche
et elle a été meurtrière
nous rejoignons en direct de rouen marc
sahi qui nie huit pole en normandie les
vents soufflent avec des pointes de 140
km/heure depuis 13 heures 13 heures
heure à laquelle la cheminée de
ventilation de la tranche 1 de palluel
s'est en partie écroulée sur le toit du
bâtiment des auxiliaires nucléaires
la tranche a été immédiatement arrêtée
bien sûr il n'y a pas de victimes et
selon la direction pas de conséquence
pour la sûreté nucléaire et à 16h le
ferry assurant la liaison dieppe
newhaven lancé un appel de détresse
actuellement il serait à l'abri des
côtes dieppoise à rouen les sapeurs
pompiers ont reçu des milliers d'appels
et effectué plus de 300 sorties à
bonsecours dans la banlieue rouennaise
d'énormes blot de la basilique
classé monument historique se sont
écroulés à aumale un camion s'est
renversé et le conducteur est mort à
fécamp le relais tdf penche
dangereusement
en tout cas on ne compte plus les
toitures arrachées les hangars écroulé
le trafic sncf est perturbé en raison
des arbres qui sont tombés sur les voies
et depuis 17 heures c'est le pont de
tancarville qui est bloqué alors sur
place au havre on retrouve olivier
levasseur
dès ce matin les premières rafales
active est dangereusement la mer des
creux de plus de 4 mètres et les
traditionnels vagues qui viennent se
fracasser contre les digues les derniers
chalutier qui s'était hasardé rentrait
quant à eux précipitamment au port la
tempête allait connaître son paroxysme
un peu plus tard en début d'après-midi
les sirènes de véhicules de pompiers
commençaient alors leur ronde incessante
les rafales atteignant quelquefois 130
kilomètres/heure ici sur la côte bien
moins qu'à l'intérieur puisque sur la
route du havre la direction du pont de
tancarville décidé de stopper toute
circulation sur ce pont après que deux
véhicules un semi remorque et une
camionnette se soit couché la
gendarmerie des vies alors camions et
voitures sur le pont les rafales
atteignaient 180 km/heure en levant a
subi de fortes point de vers 15h 15h30
et il était absolument impossible de
tenir debout sur le pont et les
véhicules risquer de faire des embardées
d'encre il a été jugé indispensable de
couper complètement la circulation
et voilà et selon la météo les vents
souffleront encore jusqu'au milieu de la
nuit
voilà ce qu'on peut dire pour l'instant
potes mais merci marc d'être intervenu
en direct de rouen michel tour et nous
donnera à 19h57 d'autres précisions et
notre prévision sur cette tempête
tous les amis de malik oussékine ont
défilé aujourd'hui au palais de justice
ils ont permis aux jurés de mieux
connaître la personnalité du jeune homme
frappé à mort par deux policiers dont le
procès a commencé lundi procès suivi par
élise lucet tout l'après-midi le
souvenir de malik oussékine a plané sur
la salle d'audience ses frères ses
soeurs ses amis un prêtre et ses
professeurs se sont succédé à la barre
pour évoquer sa personnalité la première
à témoigner sa soeur sarah 26 ans on
était comme tous les enfants ont joué on
se chamaillait c'était quelqu'un de très
calme très tranquille jamais agressif
oui monsieur le président il avait une
activité tout à fait normal il faisait
du sport du judo du basket
il était très brillant à l'école alors
vous comprenez je ne les jamais
considéré comme quelqu'un d'handicapés
jamais la politique
nous sommes une famille très ouverte
très tolérante malik s'est même inscrit
au rpr mais c'était juste pour voir pour
comprendre
vous savez il était même plutôt
conservateur toujours en costume cravate
et puis très concerné par la religion il
avait rencontré un prêtre à l'hôpital ça
l'avait beaucoup marqué la salle
d'audience écoute très attentive
tout à coup la voix de sarah s'étrangle
brisée par l'émotion elle fixe schmitt
et garcia
pour moi c'est vous qui l'avaient
tabassé à mort alors ne me regardez pas
dans les yeux
j'aimerais bien savoir pourquoi vous
vous êtes acharné sur lui ce qui est
arrivé est tellement injuste
c'est un coup de poignard dans le dos le
massacre de timisoara en roumanie qui
avait horrifié le monde entier at il été
commis comme on l'a dit à l'époque par
la police secrète de ceausescu ça n'est
pas sur les témoignages recueillis par
rtl allemagne permettent d'en douter
il est possible que les révolutionnaires
est en fait monter toute une mise en
scène en sortant des cadavres de
l'institut médico légal de la ville
philippe pisteurs nous en dit plus
l'étudiant
22 décembre au soir en plein coeur de la
révolte à bucarest en direct de la
télévision roumaine les télés du monde
entier découvrent ces images horribles
le charnier ces cadavres recousu ne sont
alors présentés comme les dernières
victimes des bourreaux de la securitate
et images terribles qui achève de
bouleverser le monde
ce bébé nous dit-on torturé avec sa mère
un mois plus tard la vérité apparaît
tout autre c'est là qu'ils étaient
enterrés le petit enfant déclare ce
médecin légiste de l'institut
médico-légal de timisoara
je n'écris pas sa mère et nous l'avons
autopsiés elle est morte d'intoxication
alcoolique
autre témoignage cette infirmière du
service des autopsies
le 22 décembre j'étais en charnier j'ai
essayé d'expliquer que ces morts
provenaient de mon hôpital septembre sur
la photo qui a tout organisé
on ne m'a pas cru tout le monde a répété
ce qu'il disait alors que c'était faux
honoré devant ce fait une macabre mise
en scène
il ne s'agit pas de mettre en doute la
réalité de la cruauté de la dictature
chercher ce coût reste une manipulation
qui ternit un peu plus l'authenticité de
certains événements de la révolte
roumaine
les téléspectateurs du monde entier qui
avait suivi avec émotion les événements
de roumanie avaient tous été
impressionnés et nous aussi par le rôle
que la télévision roumaine avait joué à
l'époque il n'était évidemment pas
question de nier le courage des hommes
et des femmes de roumanie qui ne voulait
plus de la dictature les permet tout de
même de se poser des questions sur le
pouvoir de l'image qui peut être
bénéfique dans certains cas mais aussi
pervers dans d'autres cas cela devrait
nous inciter nous-mêmes à nous
interroger sur notre métier de
journaliste à la télévision en
azerbaïdjan les nationalistes continue
de résister aux soldats soviétiques hier
soir l'armée rouge a dû dégager au canon
le port de bakou en tirant sur le
pétrolier qui bloquaient les accès le
point sur la situation avec hélène
risacher
le états au valium puis ben écoutez le
peuple ou des commentateurs belges en
donner la liberté à l'intervention de y
pleure et fleurs pour leurs morts les
azéri manifestent aussi leur
détermination nationaliste gorbatchev
veut un deuxième afghanistan il l'aura
en azerbaïdjan c'est ce qu'a dit tout à
l'heure à moscou et tibor mammadov l'un
des dirigeants du front populaire
d'azerbaïdjan
les nationalistes algérie veulent
soumettre l'indépendance de leur
république un référendum à sourcils
armée soviétique ne se retire pas la
guérilla sera inévitable malgré une
centaine d'arrestations l'armée a du mal
à maintenir le calme dans bakou
régulièrement les soldats en patrouille
sont attaqués par des commandos
d'algérie à moto qui les mitraillent et
s'enfuit la guerre des partisans
s'installe écrit le quotidien du
gouvernement les izvestia bas coûts
restent paralysées par la grève générale
le parti communiste a dû se réunir cette
nuit par crainte des manifestations à
bas coûts
cette session extraordinaire a décidé le
limogeage du secrétaire général du pc
d'azerbaidjan remplacé par le premier
ministre de la république
moscou cherche à éviter l'enlisement du
conflit et le pc d'azerbaidjan aurait
entrepris des négociations avec le front
populaire azéri les pays occidentaux
suivent évidemment avec attention ce qui
se passe en azerbaïdjan et en europe de
l'est mais états unis surtout qu'ils
sont à la fois ravis d'assister à la fin
mouvementée du communisme mais qui sont
peut-être aussi perturbé il avait fait
comme d'autres de l'anticommunisme un
fonds de commerce florissant
comment dans ces conditions difficiles
ce changement laurence piquet son équipe
ont tenté de le savoir en se rendant à
munich dans deux radios américaines
destiné aux pays de l'est
reportage dans cette fiction azéri 500
coups de fil reçus chaque jour
d'azerbaïdjan la population raconte
l'horreur des affrontements avec l'armée
soviétique à ce journaliste
ce matin lors de la conférence de
rédaction priorité donnée à bakou
questions futiles comparées
l'azerbaïdjan à l'afghanistan
réponse non l'accent sera mis sur la
réaction washington et sur l'avenir de
gordon chauffe
radio svoboda radio liberty propose ce
soir à ses auditeurs de nombreux
témoignages et une interview de kasparov
en 1950
radio free europe radio liberty sont
créés par la cia croisade pour la
liberté combat contre le communisme avec
les dollars de la vérité deux radios que
l'on s'est acharné à brouiller à l'est
jusqu'à l'année dernière radio liberty
est reçu à présent par toute l'urss
radio free europe par cinq autres pays
de l'est
total de l'audience grâce à cet émetteur
à munich plus de 60 millions de
personnes
une station bunker encore protégée par
un mur d'enceinte mesures de sécurité
toujours stricte après un attentat à la
bombe en 1981 aujourd'hui radio free
europe radio liberty met l'accent sur
l'objectivité de ses journalistes
le cordon ombilical avec la cia est
coupé depuis près de 20 ans le congrès
américain finance a certes mais c'est au
nom du droit de tous à l'information
la diffusion se fait en 23 langues
n'intervenant pas nous ne nous
substituons pas un pacte à décisionnel
aux mains nous nous bornons à relater à
commenter analyser à comparer ici dans
la section roumaine arrivent chaque jour
300 lettres de mécontentement face au
pouvoir politique
autant dire que le travail de la station
est loin de s'achever
nous pensons que notre principal travail
aujourd'hui c'est bien sûr la diffusion
de l'information pour la population mais
au delà il faut aider aussi cette
population à mettre en place la
démocratie dans ce secteur à munich
l'existence de radio free europe radio
liberty n'est donc pas menacé dans les
prochaines années
la preuve deux bureaux viennent d'ouvrir
l'un à budapest
l'autre à varsovie
une bonne nouvelle baisse du chômage en
1989 mais une bonne nouvelle qu'il faut
relativiser
c'est michel rocard qui le dit lui-même
le recul du chômage est insuffisant
estime le premier ministre
les précisions de henry lauret la france
comptait un peu plus de deux millions et
demi de chômeurs au 31 décembre 89
une statistique officielle fondée sur
les demandeurs d'emploi inscrits à
l'anpe d'une année l'autre ces chiffres
traduisent une amélioration de 2,1 pour
cent en chiffres corrigés des variations
saisonnières ce qui correspond à 60
mille chômeurs de moins qu'à fin 88
amélioration aussi au plan des créations
avec 230 mille emplois nouveaux
un bilan qui peut paraître satisfaisant
mais qui demeurent insuffisants la
france occupe toujours un rang modeste
dans la cee
avec 9,4 pour cent de sa population
active à la recherche d'un emploi quant
au chômage longue durée il s'aggrave et
durent en moyenne 360 deux jours
l'intérim en revanche est en plein boom
jean marc pitte nous résume les autres
événements de la journée
l'instruction de la sphère paul touvier
ne sera pas un monopole lyonnais ainsi
en a décidé la cour de cassation le 30
novembre dernier une requête lui avaient
été présentées pour joindre les deux
dossiers de l'ancien chef de la milice
yonnaise devant le tribunal de lyon au
cas échéant et si le bon fonctionnement
de la justice l'exigé le juge
d'instruction parisien hériterait de
l'ensemble
un bruit qui court c'était pourtant une
affaire qui marchait bien cette société
de franche et du va proposer aux
commerçants le lancement publicitaire de
leur magasin et un stock de gadgets et
d'accessoires de mode
aujourd'hui elle se révèle être une
vaste escroquerie elle accuse un gouffre
de 120 millions de francs
200 gérants sont victimes de cette
banqueroute
alors que la grève des urgences été
remplacé dans de nombreuses régions par
celle des soins les internes et chefs de
clinique de toulouse ont testé une
nouvelle forme d'action
ils ont proposé des consultations
gratuites sous un chapiteau installé
place du capitole en plein centre ville
et même si la toile de tente avait tout
d'un cirque les médecins ne sont pas
passer pour des clowns
alain gardère la grande dame de
hollywood des années 40 et 50
henry chapier me dirai si je dis une
bêtise tout à l'heure est morte
l'ancienne épouse de frank sinatra avait
68 ans dominique poncet retrace sa
carrière plus atteint avec une vie à
hollywood
et c'est là chez bt meyer l'avez
remarqué est engagée en 1941 à 50 $ par
semaine
deux panneaux insignifiante ont fait jeu
égal avec celui par devenir star en 1952
les neiges du kilimandjaro avec été son
premier film en tête d'affiche d'autres
chefs-d'oeuvre devait suivre dont la
comtesse aux pieds nus les 55 jours de
pékin et la nuit big bang mais cette
femme qui a vécu trois maris successifs
mickey rooney artichauts et frank
sinatra n'avait en fait jamais connu le
bonheur est le disais j'ai été victime
de mon image je suis en fait d'une
timidité maladive
j'ai les valeurs d'une fille de campagne
elle disait encore j'aurais changé ma
carrière contre un mariage long et
durable
ava gardner décédé aujourd'hui des
suites d'une pneumonie elle avait 67 ans
j'ai dit star tout à l'heure henri le
mot star est évidemment galvaudé
aujourd'hui mais en quoi
ava gardner est et l histoire différente
des autres mais vous avez quand même
raison de l'utiliser pole parce que
c'est une des plus grandes stars et
c'est un mot qui veut dire quelque chose
dans le cas de lagardère
d'abord parce que dès qu'elle apparaît
sur l'écran était fasciné c'est ça qui
est extraordinaire
elle pouvait ne rien dire au sujet de la
voir et alors de très grands signèrent
qu'ils ont compris d'abord siodmak en 49
qui voulait elle avait l'air d'une femme
fatale
avant même qu'on dise moteur c'est ça
qui comptait beaucoup mais alors
certains cinéastes hollywoodiens ne se
sont pas vendus tout à fait content il
va essayer de la faire glisser à
l'intérieur d'un film pour savez une
histoire et puis il ya eu des exceptions
fabuleuse il est a u pandora il y a eu
la comtesse aux pieds nus
alors justement on vient d'entendre demi
qu'on s'est parlé de ce côté si vous
voulez du rêve de toute femme les femmes
qui écoutent ce journal le comprennent
et ils veulent être heureuse
elles veulent être évidemment à l'aise
riche peut être célèbre d'avoir une
femme veut être heureuse un magasin ne
l'a pas été alors précisément tout à
l'heure on parlait avant même ce journal
et vous m'avez dit oh elle avait une vie
tumultueuse alors quelle était la nature
de ce tumulte et bien d'abord dans ce
métier qu'ils voulaient et l'été et
l'inspiré aussi à son propre personnage
par exemple dans la côte et son pied nu
cette guitare avait des caprices de
petite fille et d'enfants mais ce n'est
pas des vrais cabri aux réalités de
cette femme était vulnérable et ne
voulais qu'une chose être brillant dans
ce métier est un peu heureuse comme tout
le monde
merci envie une nouvelle qui va faire
plaisir ou cinéphiles qui n'ont que 16
ans garçons ou filles qui sont
impatients d'aller voir des films qui
leur sont interdits je viens d'apprendre
à l'instant réforme de la censure au
cinéma abaissement de 18 à 16 ans de
l'interdiction de certains films aux
mineurs décision prise par jacques lang
ce journal est terminée à 22h15 markut
mans vous présentera soir 3 demain la
journée infos sur la trois
commencera exactement à midi avec anne
de coudenhove puis ensuite avec
catherine matausch michel tu aurais tout
à l'heure pour la météo bonsoir à demain